[Music]
as you we are standing at this point now
if your friend tells you there is a
treasure pot 50 kilometers away from
home how long will you take to find it
which direction will you go it could be
here or here or maybe here it is hard to
know where exactly it is you are only
provided the distance which is one
dimensional information one dimensional
information like this is called a scalar
quantity your question to him would be
which direction from home when you are
told that it's 50 kilometers in the
northeast direction you have to precise
information of the location this now
becomes two dimensional information
distance and Direction the treasure pot
is over here two dimensional information
like this is called a vector quantity
scalar quantities are one dimensional
and vector quantities are two
dimensional speed is a very good example
of what we call in physics a scalar
quantity indicating only magnitude but
not specifying any direction so that's
what scalar quantities are only
magnitude but no direction in the case
of velocity however the direction is
stated and that's why it is referred to
as the vector quantity a vector quantity
involves not just the magnitude but also
the direction then you add directional
information to speed it becomes a vector
quantity called velocity the additional
information makes it more specific
temperature change for example is one
dimensional quantity but when we specify
rising or falling temperature it is two
dimensional if someone says that the
temperature has changed by two degrees
we won't really know if it has increased
or decreased we will look at various
scalar and vector quantities in the next
few tutorials and for as long as we
study physics speed velocity distance
displacement mass weight force at
generation the more we look at these but
Kira this concept will become